ho 36 anni e da 13 vivo all'estero
ho iniziato con l'erasmus poi tra master
il lavoro ho fatto tappa a madrid londra
e parigi dove viveva ormai da dieci anni
e ogni giorno a colazione pranzo e cena
mi domando se ho fatto la stessa la
scelta giusta perché sono partito perché
avevo voglia di avere una formazione
internazionale imparare lingue
avevo voglia di recuperare anche un po
della mia identità
essendo il quarto figlio quindi di una
famiglia numerosa volevo ritagliarmi il
mio spazio anche all'interno della mia
famiglia e quando mi sono allontanato
quindi quando sono andato all'estero
visto che qualcosa mi mancava mi
mancavano tutti quei momenti con la mia
famiglia che erano scanditi anche dalle
abitudini quotidiane e mangiare per
esempio e quindi ogni volta che tornavo
in italia per sentirmi un po a casa era
sempre la stessa bella storia riempivo
il mio trolley con un con il cibo di cui
avevo voglia
ovvero con il caffè della mattina con il
biscotto della prima colazione la
merendina della ricreazione a scuola
ecco io faccio parte di quella
generazione che ha vissuto il trattato
di maastricht quindi sa che cosa
significa essere europeiste sono un
europeista convinto credo nell'europa
come terra di opportunità di diversità
volemose bene però la panna sulla
carbonara non ci va questo è chiaro
proiettiamoci quindi in norvegia per
farvi sentire un italiano all'estero
quindi fammi capire tu sei venuto in
italia hai assaggiato la nostra cucina e
poi hai pensato di aprire un ristorante
italiano qui si sentì un po come lo
cucino in questo spaghettino qui
battelli quindi acqua in miti pasta
accendifuoco
30 minutes invece la facevo bollire fans
che è stronzo
sapete quanti italiani quanti checco
zalone ci sono all'estero sono più di 5
milioni nell'ultimo rapporto migrantes
del 2019
la fotografia è chiara non è più la
popolazione dal sud italia che migra
verso il nord ma è la nazione italia che
migra verso l'estero sono basate gli
occhi tre dati il primo è questo l'età
media
l'italia è tra i media ed i 45 anni in
irlanda per inciso e 37 l'età media
questo perché perché i giovani vanno via
perché c'è un basso tasso di natalità e
giovani quanti giovani vanno via un
milione e 200 e tutti questi
giovanissimi al posto di stare in italia
vanno all'estero e creano delle proprie
vere nazioni di italiani all'estero
negli ultimi dieci anni c'è stata una
crescita del 70 per cento cioè sono
passati da 3 milioni di italiani
all'estero a più di 5 milioni di
italiani all'estero
immaginatevi adesso la popolazione
dell'abruzzo del friuli venezia giulia
insieme all'estero che sono tutti gli
italiani che sono in europa quindi due
milioni e mezzo
ma chi sono questi italiani che sono
all'estero però racconto io con le mie
esperienze ho incontrato persone dalla
generazione dei paninari quindi quelli
che sono nate negli anni settanta forse
qualcuno si riconosceva in questo stile
ormai passato fino ai millenni als e
nelle nostre cene nei nostri momenti di
incontro nelle nostre chat eravamo
sempre lì a dire ci manca qualcosa ci
manca qualcosa
abbiamo tanta nostalgia di casa perché
ci mancano quei prodotti che ci fanno
sentire a casa che sono stati parte del
nostro essere di quando eravamo giovani
quindi questo senso di nostalgia come lo
colmiamo l'italiano si sa non si
rassegna l'italiano si ingegna e quindi
la prima cosa da pensare il fai da te
chiedo alla mamma di preparare il pacco
della mamma di fare la spesa andare alle
poste inviarmi il tracking che io seguo
con tanta tanta attenzione e vedere
questo tra
che va sulla transiberiana poi passa per
i paesi baltici e poi arriva finalmente
a parigi e magari la mamma acceso anche
un ciro affinché questo pacco non arrivi
distrutto ecco per farvi capire quanto
amore e quanto importante è un pacco per
italiano all'estero
ho preso una poesia di daniele
virgillito altro italiano all'estero a
berlino letta proprio da mia madre
le mamme lontane hanno il cuore in
trasferta e guardano il metodo di
un'altra città
sorridono tristi a una stanza deserta e
mandano pacchi di felicità
oltre a questo al metodo tradizionale
della mamma quando sono a parigi cosa
faccio scendo vado a trovare qualche
prodotto al supermercato ma se lo trovo
lo trovò caro non trovo tutto ciò che
voglio altrimenti vado da quelle
botteghe italiane che io definirei
gioielleria dove sacrilegio la pasta
costa 3 euro che per noi è un'assurdità
perché è quel prodotto con il quale io
sono cresciuto e mi devo devo sentir
dire trattato quasi come un turista di
pagare quel prodotto che è stato mio
così tanto
ecco tutte quante queste non possono
essere delle possono sembrare delle
lamentele da italiano un ostaggio che
sono all'estero ma i prodotti realmente
mancano perché i prodotti danno un senso
di appagamento sono è il nostro e nostra
valvola di sfogo per dire sono ancora io
nonostante sono fuori dal contesto in
cui ero prima come come vi potete
sentire voi se in questo momento foste
voi al posto mio
a parigi senza questo pezzo identità
vostra
ecco potete farlo trovando nei vostri
sacchetti ted un barattolino al cui
interno è racchiuso del basilico
vi invito a farlo a prendere questo
baratto che si trova dentro e a odorare
il basilico e capire come ci si sente
meglio nel momento in cui con la mente
si ritorna indietro al proprio al
proprio passato
ecco proprio partendo da questo durante
le mie cene
ci siamo ci siamo detti possiamo fare
questa cosa la diciamo sempre di poter
fare un pacco da giu
ma non ci riesce mai perché tra il dire
e il fare c'è di mezzo il mare e quindi
con tutto questo vortice di emozioni che
i prodotti portano non sono accessibili
agli italiani all'estero
io sono un entusiasta del web adoro l'e
commerce
credo nella magia di vedere un patto che
parte dall'italia arriva sui
pianerottoli degli italiani all'estero
in tutta europa e quindi con romolo
altro italiano all'estero in ginevra
abbiamo pensato di digitalizzare il
pacco della mamma come modellizzato il
processo a livello di business a livello
operativo e rendendo così accessibile a
migliaia milioni di italiani all'estero
la possibilità di avere finalmente quei
prodotti magari anche al giusto prezzo
ecco i momenti più belli sono stati
proprio quelli durante il lock down nel
momento più difficile
il romano ci siamo detti da imprenditori
è una missione per noi sentire la
gratitudine della community degli
italiani all'estero persone che stanno
vivendo la nostra stessa situazione e
durante il periodo di rocco danno questo
è stato l'esempio chiaro era un momento
difficile per tutti un momento in cui
l'italiano all'estero non poteva
rientrare in italia era il momento prima
di pasqua è il momento in cui la catena
logistica era totalmente stressata e
quindi si dovrà aspettare 10 15 giorni
per ricevere la spesa a casa noi abbiamo
tirato su un magazzino in pochi giorni e
abbiamo assicurato la pasqua con i
prodotti tramite la pastiera il grano
cotto cioè d'arancia le uova di pasqua a
migliaia di italiani all'estero ci siamo
sentiti enormemente gratificati ecco io
e romolo non abbiamo inventato né la
mamma nel pacco steve jobs non è
inventato nella musica nel telefono lui
però ha visto un'intuizione di
un'esigenza delle generazioni future
io ho realizzato la mia idea
imprenditoriale
grazie alla riscoperta della mia
identità
invito
i giovani imprenditori che ci sono in
questa sala a pensare introspettivamente
a quale è la propria identità e
soprattutto a dire ognuno di voi ha una
chiave ha un talento questa serratura
può essere anche all'estero
però vi invito a trovarla qui in italia
dove le risorse sono e straordinarie ed
eccellenti grazie